usted o alguien que usted quiere puede
haber sido diagnosticado con cáncer de
pulmón este vídeo le ayudará a entender
más sobre el cáncer de pulmón y cómo
afecta a su cuerpo
y los pulmones son un par de órganos
dentro de su pecho que le permiten
respirar
usted inhala oxígeno que todas las
células necesitan luego exhala un gas
residual llamado dióxido de carbono
este intercambio de gases ocurre dentro
de pequeños alvéolos sacos de aire de
los pulmones el cáncer de pulmón es una
enfermedad en la cual las células
pulmonares normales se transforman en
células dañinas llamadas células
cancerosas anormales las células
cancerosas se multiplican y forman
grupos llamados tumores estos tumores
crecen y destruyen el tejido pulmonar
sano el cáncer de pulmón puede
extenderse a otras partes del cuerpo a
través de la sangre o la linfa una
sustancia natural que ayuda a recoger el
material de desecho que el cuerpo no
necesita
hay dos tipos principales de cáncer de
pulmón cáncer microcítico de pulmón de
células pequeñas y cáncer no microcítico
de pulmón de células no pequeñas llevan
su nombre por los tipos de células que
tiene el cáncer y por su apariencia bajo
el microscopio el cáncer no microcítico
de pulmón es el tipo más común de cáncer
de pulmón el cáncer microcítico de
pulmón es el tipo más agresivo de cáncer
de pulmón crece y se expande más
rápidamente el factor de riesgo más
importante para el cáncer de pulmón es
el tabaquismo otros factores de riesgo
incluyen tabaquismo pasivo
exposición al radón
y antecedentes familiares de cáncer de
pulmón
infección por vih
exposición a sustancias químicas nocivas
como el asbesto
y contaminación del aire
el cáncer de pulmón puede no presentar
síntomas en sus primeras etapas cuando
aparecen los síntomas estos pueden
incluir tos crónica dolor en el pecho
dificultad para respirar tos con sangre
ronquera pérdida de apetito dificultad
para tragar pérdida de peso cansancio e
hinchazón del rostro o el cuello
si usted tiene cáncer de pulmón el
médico tendrá que determinar la etapa o
la evolución de la enfermedad que lo
ayude a planificar su tratamiento
el cáncer no microcítico de pulmón tiene
muchas etapas en la etapa oculta las
células cancerosas se encuentran solo en
los fluidos pulmonares en la etapa 0 se
encuentran células anormales o
cancerosas en el revestimiento de las
vías respiratorias
para la etapa 1 se encuentra un pequeño
tumor
luego en la etapa 2 el cáncer ha crecido
diseminado a los ganglios linfáticos o
tejidos no pulmonares cercanos en la
etapa 3a el tumor ha adquirido un cierto
tamaño además el cáncer se encuentra en
los ganglios linfáticos del mismo lado
del pecho o en órganos cercanos
la etapa 3 ve es similar a la 3a pero en
la 3 ve el cáncer se encuentra en los
ganglios linfáticos del lado opuesto del
pecho el cáncer también puede
encontrarse en los ganglios linfáticos
encima de la clavícula en la etapa 4
pueden encontrarse tumores en ambos
pulmones
además el cáncer puede haberse
diseminado a órganos distantes hay un
menor número de etapas para el cáncer
microcítico de pulmón en su etapa
limitada el cáncer se encuentra en sólo
uno de los lados del pecho en la etapa
extendida el cáncer se ha diseminado al
otro lado del tórax oa órganos distantes
si se enfrenta a un diagnóstico de
cáncer de pulmón continúe conversando
con su médico y su equipo de atención
del cáncer